let's make the case for a free state
project in pro probably maybe in a way
you wouldn't be your first go to let me
pull this story
this is from cnn the workers who keep
global supply chains moving are warning
of a system collapse
seafarers truck drivers airline workers
have endured quarantines travel
restrictions and complex covenanting
vaccination and testing requirements to
keep stretched supply chains moving
during the pandemic in an open letter
wednesday to heads of state attending
the united nations general assembly the
international chamber of shipping and
other industry groups warned of a global
transport system collapse if governments
do not restore freedom of movement to
transport workers and give them priority
to receive vaccines recognized by the
world health organization we got trucker
shortage this year we got him in the uk
the idea that you
will be able to just float in this
system and things are going to go like
normal like you can walk to the grocery
store and there your strawberries is is
a joke it's not true people need to
start being responsible for themselves
because they are telling us the system
is collapsing but i got one more for you
from timcast.com 82 of americans are
scared that supply chain issues will
ruin their life plans oh all right then
82 percent of people already know this
well here's an option you can get a
hundred acres in new hampshire for like
200 grand
and then just uh start getting to it
start working the free state project is
social security for people who don't
believe in social security
so what do you what do you think is
going to happen um if
i mean what's the ultimate goal free
state new hampshire succeeds or what so
the the project takes no stance on
secession um the like so the ideas again
just get people here um i think this is
my i'm not giving my personal opinion
like
i'm totally cool with the session i
would love it if it happens i think
there's a huge opportunity to simply
push nullification right like
nullification gets done a lot what's the
most successful anarchist or libertarian
movement in the united states i don't
want to venture a guess no
the amish
yeah yeah the amish don't pay social
security what really yep why not because
the 200 000 of them got together and
said screw you we're not doing it
the amish don't have to participate in
the draft what yeah they're the only
organization they're the only people
exempt from the draft wow yeah so when
you have a
there's an aspect of government that's
like very much sour grapes in terms of
what it wants to control and by that i
mean if the if the government can't
control something it acts like it never
wanted to right right right right and so
if you have enough people who are
willing to get together and say no screw
you like people people started their own
city in seattle and there was not the
government will yeah to go in and
control it well until they went to the
mayor's house or or right right but if
you get enough people together in one
place and they're willing to say screw
you like i the federal government is not
going to wage a civil war right and so
like i think if you want to achieve
secession which i'm totally cool with
i'm not trying this is not like an
anti-succession i support it but like
you can do a lot of things you can say
well we're not going to participate in
these federal programs we're not going
to give you this money we're not going
to collect income tax from new hampshire
residents right and you can play this
sort of game of brinksmanship where
you're pushing it on them to do
something well the reason i ask about
secession is you know
watching what happened what we're seeing
in the economy right people need to
understand the m1 money stock is just
skyrocketing they they opened up savings
accounts so that everyone can use
savings like checking they removed the
reserve requirements apparently we're
just finding this out from bob murphy
they were removed reserve requirements
for giving out loans which means banks
can literally just be like here's money
whatever we have no idea
yeah the system's on fire right now
here's what happens
we have a lot of people who watch and
their attitude is the system is too
comfortable for me to do anything
differently right i don't want to stand
up and risk my family and my you know my
house and my job i got kids to feed so
i'm not going to to put them at risk for
a political cause
but i think all that they're really
saying is i will not prepare for what is
happening right before me so so i just
want to ask you like what do you think
happens to a new hampshire in the event
of a breakdown of economic trade lines i
mean are people there gonna just farm
their own food and be self-sufficient or
what i mean i think i think new
hampshire could be self-sufficient if if
necessary um i think self-sufficiency
doesn't have to mean that you're doing
everything yourself it's about like how
it can also be part of having a network
you know to do that and you know there's
a huge algorithm community there are a
bunch of farms in new hampshire there
are a bunch of people who are doing uh
who are doing their own uh thing and
i'll say to like your point about like
people not wanting to stand up i have
some sympathy to that like it's hard to
go first but one of the things you can
do is get to get together with you know
10 000 other people who all want to go
10 000 right and then you can all act
together right or just go to new
hampshire now because people are already
there exactly like you you you'll have a
better life immediately you'll get to
live with people who share your values
by far the greatest density of
libertarians in the entire world and
like if there's ever going to be
something that happens like you're there
you're going to be a part of it you
don't i and like i'm not trying to knock
being brave i think people who are
willing to be brave who are willing to
put their their head on the line i think
they're awesome and a lot of these
people are my heroes uh my personal
heroes but if if you're saying like hey
i don't want to be that guy but i still
want to win the free state project's
also a very good choice you know because
you'll you'll still get to be a part of
it but you don't have to be the very
first guy and get your head chopped off
so let's let's take a look at the you
know
the economy from a more libertarian
perspective i guess your thoughts on you
know everything i mentioned about the
banking system what they've been doing
obviously you know ian talks about the
fed a lot we we we criticize this system
but like what's your view of what's
going on with this i mean i think it's i
think it's very messed up uh i think
it's clear that there's like a lot of
inflation happening i mean as a
libertarian like my perspective on this
is like you want free banking you want a
competition in currencies like let let
the best currency win allow there to be
allow there to be competition in terms
of how currencies are going to be
provided and how they work i mean i
think there's all kinds of interesting
things you can do with money beyond even
bitcoin
that can't be done because of government
uh regulation i think david i like david
friedman had some very interesting ideas
uh you know about how to design uh free
money that was like stable and track the
price of goods um going back to the 70s
and those could be done on the
blockchain
and there's all kinds of things that you
could do but there's no doubt that the
system is is very messed up as to what
degree it collapses i mean i'm not an
economist so i'm not going to like i'm
not going to venture that but i think
it's clear that like you this is there
is like a house of cards type situation
here and to what degree it collapses you
know i don't know usually all at once
yeah especially when you look at the
world gradually then suddenly yeah with
the weight demo it looks like yes it is
collapsing but it also looks like it's
being demolished with this behavior of
shutting down the entire almost the
entire economy a large percentage of it
and mass printing of money that's like a
demolition move so i would imagine
like you said well there's that one
there's that meme where they say the
carbon they're trying to reduce is you
never seen that i'm no i'm seeing so
many people in prominent positions that
don't understand you can recollect the
carbon from the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and turn it into graphene
maybe that's not the issue ian
yeah it's no different the global
warming stuff is no different than the
covet stuff right like the people who
push it and i'm not trying to say like
global warming is real but like the
people who push it they're pushing it
for reasons of dominating other people
and that's why the focus is so much on
the on the on the communism aspects
that's why they don't care about nuclear
power that's why they don't care about
removing carbon from the environment
right that's why they don't because it's
not about that that's not why they care
i mean they're they're they're like wow
this is a problem and here's what ends
up happening they say okay climate
change is a problem right we got a whole
lot of people cranking out a whole lot
of waste mercury in the waters dead
zones bugs disappearing all this stuff
because humans are affecting the planet
what do we do well we can reduce carbon
in the atmosphere we can clean up our
oceans and like yeah but that doesn't
stop the human behavior
it won't change the fact that humans are
expanding or growing and eating and
consuming and wasting
so how do you stop it in the long run
and they say
authoritarianism
take away their stuff
don't let them live the way they want to
live convince them to live a certain way
that you want them to live because we
are right the problem is as much as we
can look at a lot of the global problems
and be like
yeah these are bad things you know like
like climate change is bad the the dead
zones in the ocean the the constant
droughts whatever you want to attribute
these things to these are bad things
affecting us and we need to be better in
tune with our environment
why should we blindly trust other people
who just think they're smarter or better
that's ultimately the problem there was
a quote we read i forgot the guy's name
maybe you guys know where he was like if
you know humans are so dumb that they
need a special class to rule them how
are these individuals who claim to be
better actually any better than the
people they claim are too stupid to rule
themselves so so what ends up happening
is they say the solution isn't to pull
carbon from the atmosphere the solution
is stop the chickens from taking a dump
in their water
or just get rid of those chickens that
are taking a dump in their water it's
it's honestly just like covered like
covets real and it kills people is is
is the debate and discussion around
covid actually about preventing that no
it's not like climate change is real and
it's going to cause uh changes and
potentially harm to our environment is
the way that climate change is discussed
and the way the policies that are being
proposed is it about solving that
problem no it's not right yeah it's
about preventing the problem rather than
treating the problem the problem's here
the problem is not going away you can't
stop people from pooping they're gonna
keep pooping you gotta reuse it unless
there's less people but technically but
that doesn't scale because there will
always be more people that's not true
well they will continue to reproduce
unless you sterilize the population and
make sense that's right that's not true
ian we're we're uh i believe in the
united states they're below replacement
now yeah and japan's been below
replacement for some time greece and
europe yeah most of the west is below
replacement free staters are above
replacement oh snap is that true what is
it globally you don't know breed them
for freedom
are you joking or what i don't know i
got three i'm doing my part
i'm kind of looking at like the ocean
cleanup this is boyan slats project in
the pacific they're cleaning up the
great garbage patch the gyre and they
did this it's on my twitter page um this
amazing they found all this trash this
is uh from one run and it's not even
from america this is from the middle of
the pacific ocean and they dumped it and
he was like we're one sixty thousandth
of the way there we're going to clean
this up and that's like 80 years away if
this doesn't even scale which it will
and the problem is that garbage didn't
come from america from the case from the
entire planet it came from our species
it mostly comes from china and india and
and southeast asia and that and that
part we know that so there's no stopping
this from happening i mean we're going
to keep dumping in the water that's it's
not we it's it's it's human i'm saying
humans are going to continue to dump in
the water we just need to figure out how
to reuse the stuff i think you need to
be more specific because
when greta tunberg comes out and looks
at one of the most environmental and one
of the countries with the most
environmentalists and says how dare you
and doesn't talk about china and india
and these other countries that are just
polluting like crazy we're not going to
solve the problem especially if china's
1.4 billion people the united states and
the west who are actually
environmentally conscious and the ones
leading the charge against climate
change they're in decline i to be honest
if i have to be the world's custodian
i'll do it i don't want to clean up
everyone else's mess but if that means
that's what we need to do to survive
i'll do it the problem is ian you can't
legislate for china no so in the united
states
where we already banned plastic straws
even though we're not contributing for
the most part to these big garbage
patches and then we go to china and
these international agreements and say
you agree not to do this today you bet
we agree not to do this and they say we
don't care we're not going to listen to
them we're going to do whatever we want
yeah well in a way waste can become very
profitable because if you can break down
the plastic back into sugar or into oil
you can reuse it so it becomes a
commodity i think that's a way to
spark cleanup
are they are they i'm i'm not a climate
scientist are they are they related like
is like
like litter and waste is not necessarily
the thing that's causing climate change
isn't climate change mostly be driven by
being driven by like the use of fossil
fuels yeah mostly methane and carbon
dioxide i think which is carbon mostly
carbon carbon ch4 is methane i think you
know the issue with climate change is
that it's a very specific claim very
very narrowed down to humans producing
too much carbon causing the climate to
change when the real thing we talked
about because we had you know we had
chris martinson on is just ecosystem
stresses and potential collapse
i'm not look climate change i get it but
it's one one facet of we have dead zones
in the gulf of mexico where chemical
runoff creates this patch with no oxygen
in the water so nothing lives we have
fisheries that are so overfished that
jellyfish are coming in and the people
start eating jellyfish it's kind of
gross but i guess they do
these are the problems we face you know
the windshield phenomenon bug
populations being decimated uh uh colony
collapse disorder bees our pollinators
are are disappearing it is not just the
one thing it is in my view
when you get eight billion people
consuming and producing tons of waste
even though we still have massive
amounts of space in this planet where
humans aren't you still have a
disproportionate amount of waste that
isn't being absorbed by the ecosystem
quickly enough that's the big issue now
how we solve that well it would be great
if we had like a real green new deal you
know in my opinion where it was actually
like hey we all agree to like stop
spending money on dumb wars and stuff
and then decide to just like hire people
and do uh
nuclear energy investment and energy
research infusion carbon regaining
insulin instead the only thing we can
get is for one republicans are totally
opposed to this and it'll never happen
to republicans and then when the
democrats finally come around aoc is
like i propose a green new deal and i'm
like oh okay i'm listening and she goes
free college for minorities and i'm like
what
that's making the problem worse yeah if
you're if you're complaining about
immigrant if you complain about america
producing too much carbon and then
you're saying bring in more people into
america where they will use more carbon
the left is literally just arguing to
make the problem worse and there is
almost no one in this country saying we
should have more nuclear energy we
should have modern advancements in
nuclear terrorists say that yeah exactly
yeah so what do we end up with
yeah the planet's still uh in trouble
humans are our disproportionate force on
this planet and it's not gonna get done
through the democrats because they're
too worried about you know minorities
not getting health care i guess i mean
it's not going to get done by other than
them and it's not going to get done by
the by the libertarians either so no for
sure i mean i you know i i will to give
at least like a little bit of an
optimistic spin like and i think a lot
of the pollution stuff where we're
actually like damaging ecosystems i
think that stuff's pretty bad but in
terms of like climate change being this
existential threat i'm skeptical of some
of that um i think that like
so i don't know if it's like scott adams
like rule about slow-moving disasters
like i think human beings are actually
like very good at solving these kinds of
problems and i think that a lot of the
hysteria
i'm not saying that's not real but
similar to covet a lot of the hysteria
is driven by a desire to to create
changes to subjugate people that the
people creating the hysteria don't like
no no exactly why is it that aoc's green
new deal had more to do with social
justice than a green new deal because
that's not her agenda her agenda is not
the climate or the planet her agenda is
identitarianism
so she'll hold up a big thing that says
climate and then everyone says i would
like to buy on to your climate plan yeah
because they don't actually read it she
decided it's like racism she abused uh
what's that guy's name
uh
roosevelt's uh new deal she just abused
the name just reused it like this this
stupid media culture where they keep
making sequels to dumb stuff you know
see here's not a nude that's if i go if
i go to if i go to the store and they i
see in the newspaper and it says you
know um
special uh moon boots you wear them and
you can jump two feet higher than normal
it's a kid's toy and then i go there and
i buy it it's a skateboard i can be like
i open the box and there's a skateboard
and i'm like this is not what you
advertised you actually i can i can file
a claim against that the government
recognizes you've lied but the
politicians that's all they do literally
everything they have is the patriot act
are you a patriot right now we can spy
on your bathroom here's a libertarian
solution to this problem that will
literally never happen like most
libertines
and it's make politicians make actual
concrete predictions about the effects
of their legislation so like literally
when you pass the bill you have to say
what it's going to accomplish and you
have to make predictions this is going
to this is going to reduce carbon by
this amount this is going to create you
know this specific amount of jobs or not
that the government can necessarily
create jobs but the point is like you
have to make specific predictions and
then you judge did it actually happen
and you make them make concrete
predictions you know i found there's two
types of problems or at least in this in
this
analogy there's two types of problems
there's problems like
you can solve them by making them not
happen that's like your son hits your
daughter smacks your daughter you say no
don't do that don't ever do that again
and then he stops
but then there's problems like global
warming creating waste you can't tell
people to stop creating waste that's not
an option in this situation it's an
endemic issue
you can consider it not a problem it's
not problems aren't bad they're they're
there to have problem solution it's in
math it's not they're not bad
but this isn't a problem that can be
solved by stopping the behavior we need
to well you need to alter the solution
well i think you need to actually adjust
the cost like and it's much more
straightforward in the case of waste
where you can like track it down and
attribute the blame and say hey
hey whoever is dumping this stuff you
need to pay this amount of money to fix
the problem i actually think from a
libertarian perspective the hardest one
is something like climate change where
it's like it's quite unclear what the
externality is of me burning a fossil
fuel of a gallon of gas what was that
externality what was the cost to it
there are people who argue that it's not
even clear that it's a negative
externality there are some people who
argue that the earth getting warmer is
actually better for humans and i'm not
endorsing that view necessarily with
other people i've seen evidence that
we're still at the end of the last ice
age but because the comets hit earth 13
000 years ago that melted all the ice it
doesn't seem like we're in an ice age
but we're actually still in an ice age
coming out of it which is why things are
warming and by the way that's from utah
uh new hampshire getting warmer is not
bad for new hampshire so from a
self-interested right
right it's not bad to have no glaciers
on earth it might be great yeah it's i
mean i mean seriously it's not like it's
it's not clear like we're we're a lot of
the climate change stuff is from the
stat from accepting that the current
status quo is what's best like cities on
the coast yeah right and and obviously
there would be costs to moving or
adjusting things or damning things but
like it's not clear that uh you know uh
an average earth temperature of two
degrees celsius higher is actually
worse for humans than the current
temperature i think but fear that floods
and things is legit fear of flooding
fresh water into the ocean killing life
is legit but it doesn't mean it's going
to be worse after it happened thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you